-"Marseille, Marchais",
huit, première.
Musique douce
-Nous sommes en 1978.
Georges Marchais,
le secrétaire général
du Parti Communiste Français,
est en campagne à Marseille.
Il est suivi
par une équipe de cinéastes.
-Peut-être faut-il que j'attende
que vous rechargiez vôtre caméra ?
...
Alors, je vais attendre.
-40 000 personnes sont présentes,
mais il choisit
de les faire patienter.
-Si, si.
...
-En homme d'image,
Georges Marchais sait à quel point
le cinéma est essentiel
pour ce que les communistes
appellent encore
la propagande de parti.
-Vous êtes prêts ?
-Ce tournage est loin
d'être le premier.
Dès sa création en 1920,
le Parti Communiste Français
a développé une intense
activité cinématographique
en impulsant la production,
la réalisation
et la diffusion
de centaines
de films.
-"La vie est à nous" a une valeur
plus historique
que cinématographique,
mais il y avait le style de Renoir.
-Unique dans le champ politique
français,
le PCF peut être considéré
comme le parti du cinéma.
-Voilà une casquette
de salopard !
...
-Nous allons vous raconter
cette histoire.
Une épopée politique
qui exprime en creux
le communisme à la française,
fait d'espoirs
et de déroutes.
Une saga cinématographique
méconnue du public,
qui n'a eu de cesse
d'expérimenter
et de se renouveler
pour contourner la censure.
Une aventure d'hommes
et de femmes qui ont fait le choix
de militer par l'image
et de prendre le parti du cinéma.
...
-Tu veux démolir
des machines ?
-Je veux tout démolir !
-Laisse ça, c'est toi,
qui es fou !
Ils commanderont des machines
et tu iras en taule.
Sérieusement,
c'est pas les machines.
En Russie, ils ont diminué
la journée de travail
et augmenté les salaires
grâce aux machines.
Ici, les gros préfèrent
nous laisser crever de faim
que de baisser leurs bénéfices.
-En 1936, le Parti Communiste
Français produit
"La vie est à nous".
La réalisation de ce film
est confiée à Jean Renoir.
Pour la première fois, un parti
politique produit un long-métrage
dans des conditions
professionnelles,
avec l'ambition de le diffuser
dans les cinémas.
-Camarades ! Au lieu de nous donner
la semaine de 40 heures payées 48,
ils diminuent le prix des pièces
et font des chômeurs !
Ca peut pas continuer !
-NON.
-Pour le PCF, c'est l'aboutissement
d'un processus
engagé 15 ans plus tôt.
En décembre 1920,
le Congrès socialiste,
réuni à Tours,
s'achève sur une scission.
Le Parti Communiste
voit le jour.
Suivant le modèle soviétique,
tous les moyens de propagande
possibles doivent être utilisés.
Le cinéma apparaît, d'emblée,
très approprié pour faire
de l'agitation politique.
Accessible à tous,
jouant sur une illusion de réel
et potentiellement reproductible
à l'infini,
c'est, pour Lénine,
le plus important de tous les arts.
Le PCF connaît ses premiers
grands succès électoraux
en 1935.
Fanfare
Les municipalités communistes
de la banlieue parisienne
deviennent un terrain d'expérience
cinématographique.
Des documentaires
sont commandés
pour promouvoir l'action
des maires communistes.
Parmi ces films,
"Les châteaux du bonheur"
est financé, en 1936,
par la ville de Gennevilliers.
-Chers enfants,
chères et chers camarades.
Le film qui va se dérouler
devant vous
va vous montrer quelques-uns
de nos efforts
et en particulier,
les résultats obtenus
à notre patronage municipal
et dans nos deux colonies
de vacances.
-Cette mise en scène du maire
Jean Grandel, un peu maladroite,
est une tentative de communication
directe, par le cinéma,
vraiment novatrice pour l'époque.
-Le jour du départ
en colonie de vacances
est enfin arrivé.
Dernières recommandations
des mamans :
"Surtout, sois bien sage,
tu nous écriras !"
On promet tout,
tant on est contents
de partir, quitte à ne pas toujours
tenir ses promesses !
-MA BLONDE ENTENDS-TU DANS LA VILLE
-Destiné à une diffusion locale,
"Les châteaux du bonheur"
prouve, en images,
l'engagement
de la municipalité
pour le bien-être des enfants.
Les journées sont rythmées
par des activités,
dont certaines
sont particulièrement fougueuses.
-IL VA VERS LE SOLEIL LEVANT
NOTRE PAYS
-L'enjeu est aussi éducatif
que politique.
-PRENEZ GARDE PRENEZ GARDE
-Il s'agit de montrer la capacité
d'encadrement et d'organisation
des communistes
du berceau au tombeau.
-QUI DESCEND SUR LE PAVE
-L'hygiène,
la santé et surtout
l'alimentation,
sont attentivement surveillés.
-C'EST LA REVOLUTION QUI S'AVANCE
C'EST LA BATAILLE
CONTRE TOUS LES COQUINS
-L'effort réalisé
par la municipalité communiste
de Gennevilliers
n'aura pas été vain.
Pesés à leur arrivée à la colonie
et à leur départ,
les enfants ont accusé
des augmentations de poids
dont les moyennes
sont éloquentes.
-Au milieu des années 30,
les communistes,
les socialistes et les radicaux
s'unissent pour faire barrage
au fascisme.
Le Front populaire est lancé.
C'est pour soutenir
la campagne du PCF
lors des législatives de juin 1936
que le projet de "La vie est à nous"
est lancé.
Chants
...
-Nous, communistes,
nous voulons bâtir un monde nouveau.
-L'idée vient de Jacques Duclos,
responsable de la propagande
du parti et grand amateur
de cinéma.
Par l'entremise de l'écrivain
communiste Louis Aragon,
le réalisateur Jean Renoir
est sollicité.
Il a alors une dizaine
de films à son actif.
Il n'est pas connu pour ses idées
de gauche et hésite à participer,
mais il partage sa vie
avec la monteuse
Marguerite Houllé, qui est proche
des milieux communistes.
C'est sans doute elle
qui le pousse à accepter.
-CAMARADE, TU N'ES PAS SEUL.
AU PLUS PROFOND DE TA DETRESSE,
TU N'ES PAS SEUL.
-Le ciel est sombre,
l'avenir t'apparaît noir,
la vie te semble sans espoir.
Camarade, reprends courage,
tu n'es pas seul.
-CAMARADE,
LA VIE EST A NOUS.
-Tourné et monté en à peine un mois,
"La vie est à nous"
invente le film militant en mêlant
fiction, documentaire
et même actualité cinématographique
détournée.
Plusieurs registres sont convoqués,
du tragique au plus comique.
Aboiements
...
Chants
"La vie est à nous"
est en grande partie construit
autour de trois histoires
introduites
par Marcel Cachin,
qui joue ici son propre rôle :
directeur du journal L'Humanité.
-C'est une lettre
d'un métallo.
-Tour à tour,
un ouvrier,
un jeune chômeur
et un paysan
résolvent leurs problèmes
par l'intervention des communistes.
-Et voilà ! Le tour est joué !
-Merci ! Merci !
-Ca n'en vaut pas
la peine.
-Ne nous remerciez pas !
-Les motivations
qui poussent Jean Renoir
à accepter d'endosser
la responsabilité d'un film
ouvertement propagandiste
restent difficile à cerner.
Plus qu'un engagement politique,
c'est pour lui une chance
d'être connu d'un nouveau public,
alors que
la France vibre
pour le Front populaire.
Musique mélodramatique
-Mon père avait une théorie
que j'aime beaucoup,
c'est la théorie du bouchon.
Il disait : "Il faut être
un bouchon dans le courant."
Il faut suivre le courant.
Bien sûr, le bouchon
doit être un peu intelligent,
pas complètement stupide
et essayer
d'aller un peu à droite ou à gauche
de façon à choisir
le moment du courant
qui lui convient
et aller, à peu près,
dans une direction qui lui convient,
mais la direction générale,
c'est les événements,
c'est le courant
qui nous la donne.
-Dis donc,
qu'est-ce que c'est
que ces gens-là ?
-Des camarades, des ouvriers.
Ils viennent là le soir, répéter.
Des professionnels les aident.
-Nous, ce qu'on voudrait,
c'est ramener en France le goût
de la musique et du théâtre.
-Ce jeune homme à droite
qui fait une apparition,
c'est Jean-Paul Le Chanois,
un des nombreux
assistants réalisateurs
sur "La vie est à nous".
S'il doit beaucoup à Jean Renoir,
le film est aussi
et même, avant tout,
une oeuvre collective.
-C'est là où je peux dire
que Jacques Becker
a fait ses premières armes,
en tournant quelques plans
du sketch des paysans.
Musique cocasse
Et moi, les miennes,
en tournant quelques plans,
dans l'usine.
-Pour Jacques Becker,
comme pour Le Chanois,
c'est le point de départ
de belles carrières
cinématographiques.
Tous deux seront des réalisateurs
reconnus les années 50.
Seul communiste de la bande,
Jean-Paul Le Chanois,
devient la cheville ouvrière
du film
en endossant le rôle
de directeur de production.
C'est lui qui gère les finances.
-J'étais caissier,
mais ce n'était pas
"l'or de Moscou"
qui payait le film.
Ca a été un meeting.
-Cette mise à contribution
des militants
complète l'argent donné par le PCF.
C'est un mode de financement
alternatif, rendu possible
par l'engagement bénévole
des équipes techniques, artistiques.
-En avant !
Sous le grand et invincible drapeau
de Marx, Engels,
Lénine, Staline.
En avant ! Pour le succès
du Front populaire !
Vive la France forte,
libre et heureuse
que veulent et que feront
les communistes !
-Debout
Les damnés de la terre
Debout
Les forçats de la faim
-Après avoir donné la parole
aux dirigeants communistes,
les personnages du film
se retrouvent
pour chanter L'Internationale.
-DU PASSE
FAISONS TABLE RASE
-L'union du peuple
est figurée et célébrée
pour incarner le programme
du Front populaire.
-LE MONDE VA CHANGER DE BASE
NOUS NE SOMMES RIEN
SOYONS TOUT
C'EST LA LUTTE FINALE
-Quand le film a été
montré, on était tous, évidemment,
un peu impatients de savoir
ce que le Parti Communiste allait
en penser.
Je me souviens que Renoir était
dans ses petits souliers.
Et je me souviens surtout
que Maurice Thorez a dit :
"Moi, je trouve ça formidable."
-GROUPONS-NOUS ET DEMAIN
L'INTERNATIONALE
...
-Les élections ont lieu
un mois plus tard.
Des voitures
et des projecteurs 16 mm
sont achetés par le PCF
pour que le film puisse être montré
n'importe où.
En mai 1936,
le Front populaire l'emporte.
Cette victoire politique renforce
la dynamique cinématographique.
Musique douce
-QUAND NOUS CHANTERONS
LE TEMPS DES CERISES
ET GAI ROSSIGNOL
ET MERLE MOQUEUR
SERONT TOUS EN FETE
-"Le temps des cerises", lui,
est un film qui a été repris
à la suite du succès
de "La vie est à nous".
Jacques Duclos a dit :
"Il faudrait
que nous fassions un film
"sur le problème
des vieux travailleurs."
*-Comptez sur nous,
vieux papas et vieilles mamans,
qu'accable trop souvent
un destin cruel.
Nous crions tellement fort
qu'on finira
par nous entendre.
-Avec "Le temps des cerises",
Jean-Paul Le Chanois gagne
ses galons de réalisateur.
Le film soutient une mesure
phare du Front populaire
et reprend les codes narratifs
de "La vie est à nous".
-Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu ?
-Les vieux.
-Les vieux ?
Quels vieux ?
-Les vieux. 20 000 vieux,
venus de partout
pour réclamer leur retraite.
Les rues étaient pleines de vieux.
-Moi aussi, l'autre jour,
j'ai vu ça.
Quand on a chassé, quand vous m'avez
retrouvé dans la rue.
Partout, des vieux.
Ceux qui sont assis sur les bancs.
Ceux qui ouvrent les portières,
ne peuvent plus les ouvrir.
Ceux qui vendent des journaux
avec des voix qu'on entend plus.
Ceux qui tirent, qui poussent
des charrettes trop lourdes.
Musique de bal musette
-"Le temps des cerises" sort
dans les salles de cinéma,
mais la critique et la réception
du public sont mitigées.
Dépasser l'entre-soi communiste,
toucher un large public
n'est pas un objectif
facile à atteindre.
...
*-Juin 1940.
Musique sombre
-La signature du pacte
germano-soviétique entraîne
l'interdiction du PC.
Après la débâcle,
le PCF, devenu clandestin,
s'investit peu à peu
dans la Résistance.
*-Avec les moyens
dont ils disposent,
des militants s'efforcent de créer
un réseau qui, malgré les consignes
de Vichy
et la surveillance de l'occupant,
pour atteindre
jusqu'au plus petit village.
-La production cinématographique
est au point mort.
A la Libération, on voit
des films qui glorifient l'action
des résistants communistes.
-Il faut que le pays sache
qu'il y a
des Français qui luttent.
La demoiselle des PTT
qui transmet
les messages travaille
pour la Résistance.
Le paysan qui ravitaille le maquis
travaille pour la Résistance.
Le terroriste
qui détruit les trains
de munitions oeuvre
pour la Résistance.
Détonation
-A la Libération,
le PCF est en position de force.
C'est le 1er parti de France,
en termes de résultats électoraux,
et d'effectifs militants.
Il participe au gouvernement
aux côtés du général de Gaulle.
Le Parti Communiste met en scène
sa propre puissance,
en finançant un reportage consacré
à la première fête de L'Humanité
de l'après-guerre,
diffusé en avant-programme
dans les cinémas.
-Chaque année, les lecteurs
de L'Humanité se rendaient en masse
à Garches.
Après une interruption de cinq ans,
imposée
par l'occupation allemande,
le Parti Communiste,
le plus grand parti français,
et le journal L'Humanité,
ont renouvelé la tradition
dans le bois de Vincennes,
qui accueille
1 million de Parisiens.
Fanfare
-Bientôt, apparaissent
sur l'immense scène à trois plateaux
les figurants
du grand spectacle inédit,
monté à cette occasion,
Ombre et Lumière.
...
Les nazis occupent notre sol.
Mais dans les forêts,
à l'appel
du Parti Communiste Français,
des patriotes se sont groupés
et organisés en groupes armés.
Ils attaquent les convois ennemis,
font dérailler des trains,
et causent des pertes sanglantes
aux SS.
*-Au nom du comité central
du Parti Communiste,
j'ai la joie immense
et la grande fierté
de remettre...
au camarade Pruvost,
un mineur de Bruay-en-Artois,
la carte du millionième adhérent
du Parti Communiste Français.
Applaudissements
-L'image est au service
d'une propagande
par le chiffre.
L'impressionnante foule rassemblée
doit montrer que le PCF est bel
et bien devenu un parti de masse.
-Le soir amènera avec lui
de nouveaux plaisirs.
Musique enjouée
-Comme partout
dans la société,
le Parti Communiste exerce
un pouvoir d'attraction important
dans les milieux artistiques
et intellectuels.
...
-François !
-Oh, madame !
-Dans le monde du cinéma,
de nombreux professionnels
adhèrent au PCF.
Pour beaucoup, ils sont également
membres de la CGT,
le syndicat majoritaire
parmi les techniciens du cinéma,
qui est sous influence communiste.
Certains compagnons de route
deviennent rapidement
célèbres dans l'après-guerre :
Gérard Philippe, Yves Montand,
ou encore Simone Signoret.
Au printemps 1946,
les gouvernements français
et américain signent
des accords économiques,
dont une annexe concerne le cinéma.
Ce sont les accords Blum-Byrnes.
Interdits sous l'Occupation,
les films américains peuvent
être importés en France,
sans restriction.
Entré au PCF
pour résister pendant la guerre,
le réalisateur Louis Daquin
devient le cinéaste du parti
dans l'après-guerre.
A la tête du syndicat CGT
des techniciens du film,
il est aux avant-postes
du combat à venir.
-L'Amérique avait produit
beaucoup de films
pendant la guerre. Nous,
nous en avions produits très peu
et ça aurait été vraiment l'invasion
du marché français
par le cinéma américain. Ca a été
une très belle bataille,
qui s'est livrée.
-Soutenant les comités de défense
du cinéma français,
la CGT et le PCF relaient
et amplifient les revendications,
tout en les utilisant pour dénoncer
l'impérialisme américain.
-Les gens commençaient
à avoir conscience
que dans toutes les difficultés
qu'avait la France,
si on ne se défendait pas,
on allait avoir
pas une occupation,
mais une colonisation très réelle.
-Spectateurs et amis
du cinéma français,
tranquillement assis
dans votre fauteuil,
venus au cinéma pour vous distraire,
et voici que ma voix,
à travers une mince pellicule
et un haut-parleur,
vient troubler votre quiétude.
C'est que, voyez-vous,
le cinéma français a besoin de vous.
Parce qu'il est en danger de mort.
-Ca a tout de même abouti
au vote à l'unanimité
moins une voix
à l'Assemblée nationale
du fonds de soutien du cinéma,
un ballon d'oxygène
prélevé en partie sur les recettes
des films américains.
-Ce fonds de soutien,
géré par le Centre national
de la cinématographie,
pose la première pierre
d'un financement régulé
par les pouvoirs publics
qui garantit encore aujourd'hui
la vitalité du cinéma.
-Vous avez été victimes...
-Cette forte implication
du Parti Communiste
dans la défense du cinéma
traduit un changement
de position politique.
En soutenant
les mobilisations sociales,
le PCF est exclu
du gouvernement
et redevient
un parti d'opposition.
Au printemps 1947,
c'est l'entrée en Guerre froide.
Musique dramatique
...
-La mine,
paysages durs et sombres
où la poussière noire
recouvre tout.
La mine !
Décor de roman,
source inépuisable d'effets faciles.
Mais la mine,
qu'est-ce encore ?
Surtout et avant tout
des hommes.
-Avec la grande lutte
des mineurs,
le cinéma communiste
change de ton.
-Les CRS envahissent les mines.
C'est l'Occupation,
comme au temps des Boches,
mais les CRS
ne remontent pas le charbon.
Ces images forcent
un terrible rapprochement.
Des enfants qui fuient
et des soldats qui montent :
images de guerre,
images
de la guerre que le gouvernement
déclare au peuple.
-Ce parallèle lourd de sens
avec l'Occupation
doit dénoncer la violence
de la répression
pendant la grève des mineurs
de l'automne 1948.
Musique dramatique
...
Réalisé collectivement,
"La grande lutte des mineurs"
a certainement été
supervisé par Louis Daquin.
...
Cherchant à concilier
son engagement communiste
et son métier de réalisateur,
il termine "Le point du jour".
Dans cette fiction
sur les mineurs,
il offre son premier grand rôle
à Michel Piccoli.
Ce tournage a sans doute permis
à Louis Daquin
d'avoir des contacts utiles
pour "La grande lutte des mineurs".
-A partir du moment
où je voulais aussi
faire un film
avec des personnages différents
de ceux que l'on montrait,
des ouvriers,
c'était normal que je sois
attiré par les mineurs.
Et alors, il s'est trouvé
que, entre-temps,
il y a eu une grande grève
des mineurs,
où il y a eu vraiment
une campagne de presse
contre les mineurs,
où on disait :
"Pourquoi font-ils grève ?
Ce sont les gens les plus payés !"
-Ce métier,
le feriez-vous,
messieurs les politiciens,
pour ce salaire de misère ?
Le feriez-vous
pour 14 300 francs par mois ?
...
-L'indignation de Louis Daquin
est partagée par les techniciens
qui réalisent bénévolement ce film,
à la demande de la CGT,
alors sous contrôle du PCF.
Les monteuses jouent
un rôle essentiel :
elles assemblent en sous-main
les images tournées
dans les bassins miniers
et récupèrent des pellicules
d'actualités cinématographiques.
Remontées avec un autre commentaire,
elles révèlent l'ambition du film :
répondre au discours
des médias officiels
avec des contre-actualités.
-En certains endroits,
les vastes opérations
de dégagement des puits
se sont accompagnées
de bagarres parfois violentes,
mais les objectifs de la police
ont en fin de compte été atteints.
-La police lance
des bombes lacrymogènes
importées d'Allemagne.
Les mineurs aux mains nues
ripostent avec ce qu'ils peuvent.
Dans cette lutte inégale,
ils rendent
coup pour coup
avec des armes improvisées.
-La Guerre froide est aussi
une guerre des images.
-Accusés d'utiliser
des armes.
Moch le menteur...
-A peine fini,
le film est censuré.
Les bobines sont saisies
par le ministère de l'Intérieur,
qui juge le film
trop subversif.
Il faudra attendre les années 70
pour qu'il soit visible.
Cris et huées
Dans ce contexte tendu,
disposer de ses propres moyens
de production et de diffusion
est indispensable pour faire
exister un cinéma de parti.
Musique enjouée
Le PCF crée
la société Procinex.
Pour être efficace,
sa gestion est confiée
à un professionnel expérimenté,
Claude Jaeger.
Il s'est illustré dans la lutte
contre les accords Blum-Byrnes
bien qu'en poste au Centre national
de la cinématographie.
Révoqué en raison
de ses idées communistes,
il prend les rênes de Procinex
pour accompagner la réalisation
de nombreux courts-métrages.
Musique musette frénétique
...
En 1949,
pour le 70e anniversaire
de Staline,
la production
de "L'homme que nous aimons le plus"
est lancée en grande pompe.
-Staline a 70 ans.
Sur les grands-routes
de France,
dans les villes et les villages,
de l'Auvergne à la Bretagne,
de la Provence à la Flandre,
de la Gascogne à la Lorraine,
c'est de partout vers Paris
que va l'amour
pour Staline.
-"Sans la victoire de Stalingrad,
notre village,
"Grigny,
serait toujours occupé
"par les nazis,
comme la France et l'Europe."
"Aussi nous tous,
paysans de Grigny,
"nous souhaitons
bon anniversaire et longue vie,
"au généralissime Staline,
qui nous a libérés par sa victoire."
Alors, vous signez avec vous,
monsieur Villard ?
-Oui, avec plaisir.
-Le film est construit
autour de la fabrication
et de l'envoi des cadeaux
à Staline.
-"Santé, Staline",
dit Picasso.
"A ta santé, Staline",
répètent les vignerons,
qui lui offrent le clairon
qui sonna les grèves du Midi
en 1907.
-Les artistes communistes
les plus célèbres
apportent volontiers
leur contribution.
Le poète Paul Eluard écrit et dit
le texte d'un commentaire
totalement décomplexé.
-Sans le coeur de Staline,
sans sa raison ardente,
les blés ne lèveraient pas
aujourd'hui pour nous.
Ceux qui les font pousser
le savent.
-Le culte de la personnalité
autour de Staline
atteint son apogée.
Avec "L'homme
"que nous aimons le plus",
le Parti Communiste
se revendique fièrement,
frénétiquement, stalinien.
*-Nous proclamons notre amour ardent
pour Staline
et nous l'assurons
de notre confiance inébranlable.
Vive à jamais
notre cher et grand Staline !
Vive le communisme !
Acclamations
...
-VIVE STALINE ! VIVE STALINE !
VIVE STALINE ! VIVE STALINE !
-Comme les deux faces
d'une même pièce,
le pro-soviétisme
va de pair avec une critique
virulente des Etats-Unis.
-En France, on aime le bon vin.
Musique guillerette
-"Les Américains en Amérique",
réalisé en 1950,
en est l'illustration parfaite.
...
-Et on sait l'apprécier.
-La bataille idéologique
se joue aussi
dans les bistrots français.
Musique virevoltante
...
-Du Coca-Cola ?
Allez, mon bonhomme !
Placez votre camelote ailleurs.
En Amérique !
Musique sombre
Musique orientale
-Tunis, capitale de la Tunisie.
-Simultanément à ces projets
impulsés par la direction du PCF,
de jeunes cinéastes communistes,
professionnels ou amateurs,
prennent seuls
l'initiative de réaliser
des films en dehors
de toute commande du parti.
C'est un phénomène nouveau.
Avec Raymond Vogel,
Jean-Jacques Sirkis ou René Vautier,
un cinéma de francs-tireurs
se développe.
Tournés à quelques mois
d'intervalle,
"Afrique 50"
et "Terre tunisienne" sont
les premiers films
anticoloniaux français.
-Moi, Muhammad,
il y a quelques années encore,
j'étais paysan.
J'avais une terre à labourer.
Je cultivais des légumes
mûrissant au soleil,
dans l'attente du marché.
Les petits enfants pouvaient courir
et s'amuser le long du chemin
qui bordait notre maison,
pendant que la femme de mon fils
mettait le pain au four.
On chante en arabe.
De cette vie laborieuse
il ne reste que ruines,
des murs croulants
et un foyer abandonné.
-Le tournage de "Terre tunisienne"
a lieu pendant l'été 1950,
avec une caméra 16 mm
et de la pellicule payées
par le parti communiste tunisien.
Dans ce pays, qui était encore
sous protectorat français,
les prises de vue sont clandestines.
Raymond Vogel
et Jean-Jacques Sirkis
se font passer
pour de simples touristes,
prenant le risque
de se faire arrêter à tout moment.
Ils peuvent ainsi enregistrer
des images rares,
pour l'époque,
de la misère et de l'exploitation
du peuple tunisien.
-Ils sont venus à Tunis,
rêvant d'une vie meilleure,
mais pour avoir un toit,
ils ont dû construire
avec de la boue et des pierres.
-Une fois tourné,
"Terre tunisienne"
n'est pas diffusé.
Le PCF ne s'intéresse pas
à ce brûlot anticolonial
et ne cherche pas à le soutenir,
jugeant qu'il ne reflète pas
suffisamment ses positions
sur la question coloniale.
...
"Terre tunisienne" apparaît donc
comme un révélateur.
Il est difficile
pour les cinéastes communistes
de s'affranchir
de la direction du parti.
...
-Pour la libération nationale,
pour la paix, la terre et le pain,
les impérialistes
croient pouvoir faire de nous
de la chair à canon,
mais nous ne sommes pas prêts
à mourir
pour le salut de notre oppresseur.
-Les blocages internes sont
une limite qui empêche
la diffusion des films,
mais le principal obstacle
vient surtout de l'extérieur.
A l'heure de la Guerre froide,
la censure bat son plein.
Pour des motifs politiques,
tous les visas d'exploitation
sont refusés.
Si le PCF parvient
à faire réaliser des films,
ils restent interdits de projection
dans les salles.
La diffusion est dans une impasse :
en restant cantonné
au réseau communiste,
le cinéma de parti ne prêche
finalement que des convaincus.
Ce constat d'un certain échec amène
le producteur Claude Jaeger
à développer de nouveaux projets
cinématographiques
au contenu moins politique.
Air d'accordéon
Le documentaire "Mon ami Pierre"
et la fiction
"Ma Jeannette et mes copains"
jouent la carte du cinéma social
et humaniste.
...
-Y a la mine
Le charbon
Le mal aux reins
Coup de pioche
Coup de ponce cigarette
Y a le boulot
Avec les copains
Y a aussi l'amour de Jeannette
-Pour toucher un large public,
la chanson titre est confiée
au chanteur et comédien Mouloudji
dans "Ma Jeannette
"et mes copains"
et à Yves Montand
dans "Mon ami Pierre".
-Mon ami Pierre est capitaine
sur le chalutier Francs-Tireurs
20 jours sur mer
Deux jours sur terre
20 jours la mer
Deux jours mari
Et l'année passe
Et c'est la vie
-Le succès est au rendez-vous :
"Mon ami Pierre" est primé
à la Mostra de Venise en 1951.
Convaincu qu'il y a
une nouvelle voie à suivre,
Claude Jaeger
dénoue les liens de Procinex
avec le PCF.
Il abandonne les films militants
pour la production
de longs métrages de fiction.
-Novembre 56,
la lueur blafarde
de l'incendie allumé en Hongrie
a fait croire un moment
à la réaction que le socialisme
allait être abattu.
-Après l'intervention sanglante
de l'Armée rouge à Budapest,
le siège du PCF à Paris
est saccagé
par des anticommunistes.
L'année 1956 est un choc.
Le rapport Khrouchtchev vient
de révéler les crimes
du stalinisme.
Le PCF refuse toute remise en cause
et n'hésite pas à trahir la réalité
des événements hongrois
pour soutenir
le grand frère soviétique.
-Le 44 est en flammes.
La police a reçu l'ordre
d'appréhender qui ?
Les camarades
qui auraient pu voler
au secours de leur parti.
A ceux-là on interdit le passage,
pour laisser les mains libres
aux autres,
abreuvés de propagande
anticommuniste
et entraînés par des fascistes
contre lesquels l'URSS
était intervenue en Hongrie
et qui s'apprêtaient
à ranimer le spectre
de la guerre en Europe.
-Cet aveuglement entraîne
une hémorragie au sein du PCF.
De nombreux militants
et sympathisants,
en premier lieu,
des intellectuels
et des artistes,
comme Raymond Vogel
ou le couple Montand-Signoret,
quittent le parti.
-Un journal dans un matin de France
-Pendant près d'une décennie,
l'activité cinématographique
se réduit considérablement,
et le PCF se recentre
sur ses propres références
culturelles et politiques.
-L'Huma sur tous les chemins
L'Huma dans toutes les mains
Bonjour bonsoir
Bon matin
Il y a le blé et le vin
Il y a la laine et le lin
Et l'Huma dans toutes les mains
Sur tous les chemins
L'Huma
*Propos télévisés
-Au milieu des années 60,
la télévision débarque
dans les foyers des Français
et devient la principale source
d'information et de divertissement.
Le PCF commande un reportage
dans l'esprit
de "Cinq colonnes à la une",
l'émission d'information
la plus emblématique de l'époque.
Le magazine "Reflets" suit notamment
la venue du cosmonaute
Youri Gagarine,
qui déchaîne les passions
à Paris et dans la cité
qui porte son nom, à Ivry-sur-Seine.
-Youri !
Youri, par ici !
-Ca faisait si longtemps
qu'on l'attendait, cet homme.
Quand il est enfin venu à Paris,
deux ans après son exploit,
ça a été une joie formidable
dans toute la France.
Brouhaha
Youri Gagarine,
le premier cosmonaute.
...
-"Reflets" poursuit la tradition
des contre-actualités communistes,
tout en profitant
des améliorations techniques
et des caméras plus légères.
-HOURRA !
-Hip hip hip...
-HOURRAS !
-On y sent à la fois
l'influence du cinéma direct
et de la télévision.
Le dispositif
du micro-trottoir
fait son apparition.
-Que représente Youri Gagarine ?
-La paix !
Un homme et la grande paix.
-La paix ?
-Oui.
-Merci, madame.
Jeune homme,
tu l'as vu, Youri Gagarine ?
-Oui, je viens de le voir,
au moment où... il était là,
devant la voiture.
-Je pense...
-Et dans la France
des 30 glorieuses,
qui change à toute allure,
la parole est aussi donnée
aux jeunes,
une classe d'âge
qui prend une importance nouvelle
dans la société.
-Ces jeunes, qui sont-ils ?
Nous les avons rencontrés
lors de leurs dernières vacances.
Nous avons surpris leurs jeux,
comme on surprend
dans la jungle
des animaux sauvages ou craintifs,
sans les effaroucher.
Car une sorte de frontière
sépare de leurs aînés
ces garçons et ces filles,
chez qui l'on découvre un appétit
de vivre féroce et joyeux.
-Avez-vous une idée,
une opinion politique ?
Un oiseau chante.
...
*Musique douce à la guitare
*...
-Ce silence, cette non-réponse,
ce n'est pas de l'indifférence,
mais beaucoup plus sûrement
une sorte de pudeur,
la crainte de dire une naïveté,
d'engager ses parents et
le respect de la lutte des adultes,
à laquelle ils ne sont pas très sûrs
d'être dignes de participer.
-ETUDIANTS UNITE TRAVAILLEURS
ETUDIANTS UNITE TRAVAILLEURS
-Etudiants unité ouvriers
Etudiants
-Quatre ans plus tard, en mai 1968,
ce sont pourtant eux
qui tiennent le haut du pavé
et secouent la France gaulliste.
C'est dans cette ébullition
que se tiennent les états généraux
du cinéma français,
qui veulent réorganiser
l'industrie cinématographique.
C'est au sein
de la commission diffusion
que de jeunes communistes du cinéma
organisent des projections,
dans les usines occupées.
Ils réalisent que les films du PC
sont inaccessibles
et dépassés.
Parmi eux, il y a Jacques Bidou.
Il a tout juste terminé
ses études de cinéma
et participe à la création
du collectif Dynadia,
avec l'envie de dépoussiérer
le cinéma du Parti.
-La première chose qu'on fait,
c'est cet outil
très rustique, très rudimentaire :
"Dix ans du gaullisme",
174 diapositives accompagnées
d'un texte lu,
c'est-à-dire qu'on est vraiment
sur du très basique,
très économique, et c'est vrai que,
d'une certaine façon,
ça a fonctionné : notre jeu de
diapositives a eu un certain succès
et on était assez fiers
de notre première initiative.
Musique enjouée
-L'après-68 est marqué par
une embellie du cinéma militant.
Des dizaines de collectifs
voient le jour, parmi lesquels
le groupe Medvedkine,
porté par Chris Marker,
et le groupe Dziga Vertov,
de Jean-Luc Godard.
S'ils rejettent le PCF
sur le plan politique,
ils s'inspirent de ses méthodes
pour produire et diffuser les films.
-CAMARADES...
-Dynadia se démarque
par son engagement au PCF,
considérant que seul
ce parti puissant et structuré
peut changer la société.
Pour agir,
le collectif réalise un film
sur la campagne de Jacques Duclos,
lors de la présidentielle de 1969.
-Ca va ? Vous avez confiance ?
-A ce moment, nous n'avons pas
comme préoccupation
la question cinématographique,
même si nous sommes cinéastes,
mais l'action politique.
D'ailleurs, on a probablement,
à ce moment,
une vision très instrumentale,
où les questions formelles
sont secondaires.
Propos indistincts
-Il représente le grand capital !
-Enfin, vous avez l'occasion
de leur dire
ce que vous pensez le 1er juin.
-Jacques Duclos est suivi,
caméra à l'épaule, au jour le jour,
ce qui permet
d'être au plus près
de l'événement politique
et de mettre en scène
la bonhomie du candidat.
Ils documentent l'irruption de
la télévision dans la vie politique.
*-Vous qui m'écoutez,
vous, Françaises et Français,
vous n'avez pas exporté
des milliards en Suisse,
pour jouer sur le deutschemark.
Moi non plus,
je n'en ai pas exporté.
Mais il y en a
qui en ont exporté, et...
-L'art de la petite phrase,
l'adresse face caméra
du candidat gouailleur,
qui cherche à se rendre sympathique,
et la mauvaise foi,
le soir du premier tour,
annonce, pour les années à venir,
la politique-spectacle
qui se développe,
avec l'essor de la télévision.
-Bon, allez.
-A voté.
-M. Duclos, sachant que le problème,
maintenant, c'est le 2e tour,
quelle sera l'attitude
du Parti Communiste ?
-Ecoutez, vous êtes trop en avance
sur le temps.
Vous faites la course
contre la montre,
mais moi, je ne cours pas !
Je ne marche pas
dans une affaire comme ça.
-La campagne de Jacques Duclos
est une réussite :
avec 22 % des voix,
il est troisième,
à l'issue du premier tour.
"Les communistes dans la lutte"
est largement diffusé
dans les réseaux communistes,
ce qui convainc la direction
de donner des moyens au collectif,
qui devient
la société de production Unicité,
avec pour devise
"Filmer pour un parti".
Musique paisible
...
Des dizaines de films documentaires
sont lancés,
en France et à l'étranger,
grâce aux financements venus du PCF.
Certains thèmes de prédilection
communistes sont repris,
comme le film de banlieue.
Pour renouveler l'approche,
une réflexion sur la forme
émerge progressivement.
En 1973,
dans "Vivre mieux, changer la vie",
l'angle choisi
est celui de l'intime.
En suivant le quotidien
d'une famille ouvrière
en région parisienne,
on présente le programme commun
autour duquel le PC et le PS
viennent de s'unir,
-Bernard Delbouix, dit "Nanar".
34 ans, marié, trois enfants.
Musique enjouée
Bien que cela
n'apparaisse pas de ces images,
et qu'ils ne soient pas
parmi les plus défavorisés
Bernard Delbouix et sa famille
vivent mal, très mal.
La crise leur colle à la peau.
-D'après ce que tu vas voir
de ta vie,
qu'est-ce qui pourrait changer,
avec le programme commun ?
-Le programme commun nous permettra
de mieux vivre,
et de vivre pleinement notre vie.
Musique douce
Un chien aboie, au loin.
Quand on aura les 40h,
si le temps de travail est réduit,
on retrouvera l'envie de faire
quelque chose. On aura le temps
et le goût de vivre.
Tous les gens qui en ont marre,
ça se retrouve
dans un bloc de grand ensemble
comme celui de La Grande Borne.
Et il y a un effort qui a été fait
pour le rendre plus agréable
pour les habitants.
Mais les gens qui y habitent,
ils n'ont pas le temps
d'en profiter :
trop de soucis.
-La mise en scène veut exprimer
l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur
dans les grands ensembles construits
par les municipalités communistes
qui sont, ici,
magnifiés par l'image.
-Je trouve qu'on peut avoir plaisir
à flâner, comme ça,
à partir un peu à la découverte,
tu vois.
Musique classique lyrique
-On a compris que, sans écriture,
ça ne fonctionnait pas,
ça ne touchait pas.
Un grand cinéaste,
qui a des choses à nous raconter,
documentaire ou fiction
- ici un documentaire -,
s'il n'y a pas de cinéma,
ça ne marche pas.
-Si une conception de l'urbanisme
comme celle-là était généralisée ?
-Les gens qui habitent ici
pourraient réellement vivre
et profiter de ce cadre.
C'est un peu ça,
le programme commun.
...
Brouhaha
-Au même moment, "Bagnolet,
carrefour de l'est parisien"
donne une tout autre vision
de la banlieue.
-Oui, Bagnolet a changé.
Et même changé beaucoup.
Le conseil municipal a pris,
il y a 15 ans,
la décision de moderniser sa ville.
Nous avons commencé
par le plateau des Malassis,
où il y avait
des terrains de culture.
-En jouant sur les références
du cinéma expérimental,
sur un ton décalé et ironique,
le montage alterné
révèle les paradoxes et absurdités
de la vie dans les grands ensembles,
ce qui remet en cause
l'action des élus communistes.
-On a ré-attaqué des chantiers
sur un chantier existant,
si bien qu'il y a énormément de gens
qui se retrouvent dans la boue,
du matin au soir, pour se rendre
à leur voiture ou au métro.
Bourdonnement de marteau-piqueur
...
-Ici, personne se connaît, à part
les voisines de palier, et encore,
on se dit bonjour-bonsoir.
Ca manque de quelque chose.
Tic-tac d'horloge
-Les réalisateurs
d'Unicité affirment
des points de vue d'auteurs
pas toujours conformes
à la ligne du PCF.
Une première fissure apparaît.
Elle s'amplifie,
avec les mésaventures
du réalisateur Gérard Guillaume.
Musique grave
En pleine guerre du Viêtnam,
Gérard Guillaume entame
une fresque documentaire.
"Les chemins de la victoire"
doit soutenir le peuple vietnamien
contre les Etats-Unis.
-L'alerte quotidienne est passée.
La défense antiaérienne sur Hanoi
est telle que tout va très vite.
Sur le chemin du retour,
les avions américains
largueront les bombes
qu'ils n'ont pas pu
déverser sur Hanoï,
de préférence sur les villages
ou sur les digues.
*Signal d'alerte
-A son retour en France,
en 1972,
Gérard Guillaume découvre
que la direction du parti
s'est alignée sur les nouvelles
positions de Moscou,
qui négocie secrètement la fin
du conflit avec les Etats-Unis
sans les Vietnamiens.
Malgré le soutien d'Unicité,
qui se positionne
contre le PCF,
le montage du film s'arrête.
Refusant de se soumettre
à l'injonction politique,
Gérard Guillaume active ses réseaux
pour aller au bout de son projet.
Il réussit à le transformer
en série documentaire pour l'ORTF.
-Au 31 mai 1972, depuis le début
de la première escalade,
plus de 3600 avions américains
ont été détruits.
Plus de 400 pilotes
ont été capturés.
Pourquoi ?
"Psyché Rock", Pierre Henry
...
-Même si des cinéastes
comme Gérard Guillaume s'éloignent,
le PCF reste
un parti attractif,
avec près de 500 000
adhérents en 1975.
...
Pour élargir encore
sa base militante,
un nouveau film est commandé :
"L'adhésion".
-"Je suis communiste,
pourquoi pas vous ?"
-Bonsoir.
-Daniel Auteuil y joue
un jeune homme inquiet
de voir sa compagne
adhérer au PCF.
-Ca y est, j'ai adhéré !
Mon bichounou !
-Non, ils t'ont changée.
Je suis sûre
que t'es plus comme avant.
-Oh, je suis comme avant !
Toi, toi, bichounou !
Allez, bisou !
-Non.
-Bisou !
-Non !
-Bisou.
-Bon...
T'embrasses plus comme avant.
-Non sans humour,
"L'adhésion" cherche
à convaincre les femmes
d'entrer au PCF.
Alors que l'émancipation féminine
est au coeur des débats en France,
la bataille est encore
loin d'être gagnée.
Musique étrange
-Pardon.
-Vous êtes communiste ?
-Oui.
-Depuis quand ?
-Oh, depuis toujours.
Depuis toujours.
-Vous avez adhéré au parti quand ?
-Euh... vendredi soir.
-Vendredi dernier ?
-Oui, vendredi dernier.
-Je peux vous demander
pourquoi vous avez adhéré ?
Propos indistincts
-Je vais prendre la parole.
J'y suis depuis longtemps.
Je fais partie du Parti Communiste
depuis X années
et ma femme
n'y était pas encore.
-Après la rupture
du programme commun,
le PS dépasse le PCF
aux législatives de 1978.
Musique légère
...
Le parti resserre le contrôle
sur Unicité
pour aller contre
le basculement politique
qui s'opère, mais le problème
reste le même :
les films ne touchent pas
le grand public.
...
-Notre échec,
par rapport au fait que
nous ne ferons pas
la révolution
de la communication
par le cinéma
en interne, est que
nous n'avons pas accès
à ce qui est en train
d'évoluer massivement,
qui est la télévision.
-La présidentielle de 1981
est un retour à la case départ.
A nouveau, la direction
du Parti Communiste
produit un film
pour suivre son candidat.
C'est "L'espoir au présent",
du nom du programme
de Georges Marchais.
-Je l'ai dit publiquement, et moi,
je le dis avant les élections.
Rires
Je dis :
"Au-dessus de 4 millions
d'anciens francs de revenu par mois,
"il faut tout prendre" !
Acclamations
...
-Malgré ses fanfaronnades
et son franc-parler,
Georges Marchais arrive seulement
en 4e position lors du premier tour.
Pour lui qui se voyait
devant le candidat socialiste,
c'est la douche froide.
L'élection de François Mitterrand
confirme et accélère
le repli électoral communiste.
"Happy birthday rock'n'roll",
Eddy Mitchell
...
Dans un style télévisuel qui n'a
plus rien de cinématographique,
le reportage consacré
à la Fête de l'Humanité de 1981
illustre
cette période charnière.
Les militants s'expriment
sur la victoire de la gauche
avec un enthousiasme relatif.
La désillusion semble poindre,
comme si le déclin politique
du PCF était inéluctable.
-Je suis un enfant de la nature
Un produit d'contre-culture
-Le changement,
c'est quoi pour vous ?
-Le changement, c'est...
respirer un peu mieux, non ?
On respire un peu mieux
depuis le 10 mai, non ?
C'est déjà un certain nombre
de décisions qui sont prises.
Ca suffit pas,
mais c'est déjà ça, non ?
-On s'aperçoit que ça vient mais,
tu vois, petit à petit,
alors on sait pas où on va.
Si les socialistes
tiennent leur parole,
on devrait être gagnants,
qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Musique intense
-Ce film est l'une
des dernières réalisations
d'Unicité, qui cesse ses activités
quelques années plus tard.
L'érosion politique
du Parti Communiste
entraîne la disparition
de sa production cinématographique.
Les années 80 actent
le passage à la communication
audiovisuelle.
...
Il reste de cette histoire
une aventure
humaine et artistique
faite de figures populaires
et charismatiques,
des centaines de films
qui sont aujourd'hui
le témoignage
d'une culture propre au PCF
et surtout la trajectoire
d'une force politique
qui aura compris
avant les autres
l'importance
de la propagande par l'image.
Acclamations
...
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
"L'internationale"
-LA RAISON
TONNE EN SON CRATERE
C'EST L'ERUPTION
DE LA FIN
...